bonsoir alexis on s'y attendait c'est
donc acté couvre-feu national d'un 18
heures et tendu donc à tout le pays à
partir de samedi et pour au moins 15
jours
oui alors c'est ce qui est formidable
avec la façon dont est géré cette crise
sanitaire le conseil de défense le
mercredi et puis sa fuite mercredi jeudi
et on sait avant que jean castex
prennent la parole le jeudi c'est le
conseil de classe le je dis attention à
ce que les français ont été sages ou pas
et on savait avant qu'il prenne la
parole que effectivement il a aidé à
lancer ce couvre-feu à 18h sur
l'ensemble du territoire dans toute la
métropole pour 15 jours couvre-feu qui
selon jean castex serait utile dans les
départements et régions qu'ils ont mises
en place mais il ya autant d'études qui
prouve le contraire et qui disent que
ces mesures en fait de restrictions des
libertés qui ne sont pas des mesures
sanitaires
rappelons le encore la façon dont cette
crise est gérée n'est pas gérée de
manière sanitaire mais de manière
autoritaire et bien ces mesures là ont
un impact extrêmement limités dans la
circulation du virus donc pourquoi
continuer à vouloir empêcher les
commerçants de pouvoir travailler alors
qu'ils ont déjà une année catastrophique
derrière eux et que ça ne va pas changer
pourquoi empêcher certains aussi
travailleur dans les grands magasins ou
de pouvoir faire leurs heures ils ne
pourront pas les faire là aussi à un
vrai problème
pourquoi continuer de vouloir absolument
désocialisés les français parce que
rappelez vous cette annonce de stanislas
guérini qui parlait de l'effet apéro
parce que pour ces gens de la république
en marche bien sûr les français n'ont
que ça à faire que de boire de l'alcool
à partir de 18 heures parce
qu'effectivement c'est la fête
les gens n'ont pas peur de perdre leur
emploi tout va très bien madame la
marquise on est vraiment dans un entre
soi dans une une gestion hors sol de
cette crise a continué avec ses conseils
de défense on apprend qu'il menait le
maquereau est toujours en colère contre
ces ministres qui font n'importe quoi
c'est lui qui décide in fine et de ce
qu'il se passe c'est lui qui est
responsable de tout ce fiasco de tous
ces pénuries
là encore ce soir on a un genou castex
très heureux très fier de dire que en
france
ces contrôles est bien mieux que chez
nos voisins mais pas un mot sur le flop
du début de la campagne de vaccination
où nous sommes bien loin derrière nos
voisins européens
donc là encore satisfecit une
autosatisfaction pour continuer à casser
le lien social pour lutter contre le
virus sociales comme le disait stanislas
vie
c'est à dire lutter contre les français
pour leur bien pour leur santé ça
commence à bien faire je crois que ces
mesures en plus ont montré toutes leurs
limites confinement couvre-feu etc
on attend autre chose que des privations
de liberté un état d'urgence permanent
de la surveillance total des pv à 135
euros parce qu'on n'est pas à masquer
dehors même quand on est tout seul dans
la forêt
ça suffit je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
flagrant que cette gestion est
inefficace première chose et qu'elle est
dangereuse pour la santé mentale des
français et des jeunes en particulier à
jean castex qui n'écarte pas un
confinement en cas de dégradation
épidémique forte ce sont ses mots est ce
que là il prépare aussi les français
éventuellement un grand continent
oui bien sûr si vous continuez dans la
petite musique ce plan tout est un peu
graduelle en france plutôt que de faire
tout d'un coup et des mesures efficaces
on prépare on essaie de voir on essaie
donc apparemment on entend c'est là
qu'il y aurait potentiellement un
confinement qui arrivera à la fin du
mois ou début février
et pour un mois parce que tous nos
voisins ont confiné parce que évidemment
quand on sait que 200 cas par jour sont
partis du variant anglais il ya une
semaine y avait quasiment pas de varier
anglais sur le territoire donc la
rapidité et l' on le savait il fallait à
l'époque où on avait connu ce mario
anglais arrêter les eurostar à la
frontière ne pas faire qu'il se déverse
gare du nord que les avions hâte
aujourd'hui on ferme les frontières
poliment avec des tests pcr avant
d'embarquer avec une déclaration sur
l'honneur de de mise en quarantaine
pendant sept jours qui va faire ça bref
et bien sûr aucun confinement avec les
pays européens tout ça c'est pour les
pays extra-européens
il ya un vrai problème dans ces gestion
de crise et c'est l'europe c'est la
façon dont l'union européenne à
commander les vaccins organisant la
pénurie de vaccins c'est aussi la
désorganisation des partenaires
européens c'est à dire que quand
certains confine d'autres ouvrent là on
voit que les écoles ferment partout
ailleurs les universités faire ben nous
on reste ouvert et on va ouvrir les
universités qui a confiné après donc y
aura toujours un temps de retard donc si
on est sérieux
soit on a une politique effectivement au
niveau européen est d'ailleurs l'union
européenne la commission européenne
réfléchit d'ailleurs dès 2010
enfin j'ai partagé un document sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya quelques temps sur
une stratégie vaccinale donc 3ème
trimestre 2010 9
il ya un plan européen de vaccination
pas sur le coville sur toutes les
maladies à vaccin pour créer un
passeport vaccinale européen une carte
de vaccins européen c'est écrit noir sur
blanc à horizon 2022 donc si on veut
faire ça alors à ce moment il faut
coordonner également les confinements
coordonner cette réponse sanitaire et
fermé les frontières intra européennes
et pas seulement extra-européenne ou
alors on laisse les gens tranquilles et
on les laisse vivre et je crois que là
c'est la question qui va se poser
le risque bénéfice de ces mesures
liberticides va arriver à un point de
rupture où les français ne vont plus du
tout accepté ces mesures parce qu'il
veut se rendre compte qu'elles sont
efficaces qu'elles les rendent
neurasthénique et qu'elles sont en train
de les rendre aussi sans emploi donc il
va falloir trouver d'autres solutions
que celle ci est le vaccin s'il en est
une n'est pas la seule est loin de là
puisque le patron de moderna a expliqué
que même avec les vaccins le virus
continuera d'être là et qu'il faut
continuer d'avoir des gestes-barrières
que ce soit le masque ou le lavage de
mains ou la distanciation
donc on est loin d'être sortis de cette
crise sanitaire mais la gestion par les
mesures liberticides ne peut pas
continuer je crois que c'est une des
grandes choses qui doit être retenu
parce que ces conseils de classe
hebdomadaire n'ont pas d'autre chose que
de préparer les français au pire
systématiquement alors un tout dernier
mot justement sur cette campagne de
vaccination qui a si elle ne réglera pas
le problème de cette épidémie elle est
en tout cas source d'espoir et de
perspectives selon les termes de jean
castex
il précise qu'à la fin de ce mois de
janvier et nous devrions être au dessus
du million de vaccinés parce qu'en fait
il y aurait beaucoup moins de pertes
dans les doses de vaccins reçus il
annonce également que dès lundi
la vaccination sera ouverte aux
personnes présentant une pathologie à
risque si elle est liée aux kobe 19 est
ce que finalement de jour en jour cette
campagne de vaccination ne sera pas
amené
accélérer mais heureusement qu'elle
accélère et heureusement qu'il ya eu
autant de critiques quand j'entends des
ténors de la majorité dire que certaines
critiques de l'opposition sont anti
patriotique non heureusement qu'il ya
des critiques pour leur faire un peu
bouger plus rapidement leur incurie et
leur façon de gérer cette crise de
manière totalement déconnecté
heureusement qu'il ya des profs qui sont
en train de hurler pour dire on veut
recevoir nos étudiants à l'université on
a besoin de les aider on a besoin d'être
là pour que le travail soit fait
heureusement que les critiques sont là
pour les pousser à travailler à faire
correctement les choses si la campagne
de vaccination accélère rappelez vous
les déclarations mi décembre c'était
censé être fin décembre quasiment déjà
un million de doses 500 mille doses qui
était reçu par semaine etc
on est loin du compte parce que bien sûr
les vaccins sont en retard parce que les
producteurs de vaccins aussi mettre
beaucoup de temps et puis parce que on
est encore en négociation et on attend
d'autres candidats vaccins aussi qui
vont arriver sur le marché européen donc
une fois qu'il en aura suffisamment on
va pouvoir vacciner mais encore une fois
le vaccin n'est pas la solution fut le
total à la crise le résultat qui va
sauver ce vaccin ça va permettre
effectivement d'éviter qu'ils aient trop
d'hospitalisation mais sur la
propagation du virus
on reste dans le doute le plus total et
puis on n'a pas encore le recul
nécessaire dans les études qui ont été
faites par pfizer biotech et les autres
sur le long terme et les effets à long
terme et la protection vaccinale les
anticorps de cette nouvelle technologie
de la rn message est donc encore une
fois c'est pas forcément sur steam aux
nouvelles mais ce ne sera pas la
solution ultime de cette crise sanitaire
alors vous l'avez évoqué rapidement le
premier ministre suivi du ministre de
l'éducation ont confirmé tous les deux
les établissements scolaires vont
finalement restés ouverts
oui et on voit bien que pour la
république en marche les établissements
scolaires font office de garderie 1 et
l'idée c'est ne pas fermer les écoles
pour que les parents puissent travailler
et peu importe si ce variant anglais
circulent davantage chez les plus jeunes
si les plus virulents on reste toujours
avec des mesures à deux niveaux
l'aération les classes restent telles
qu'elles sont on va étaler le temps de
cantine peut laisser les cantines
ouverte c'est une bonne chose pour les
élèves les plus défavorisés qui puisse
avoir un repas un bon repas une fois par
jour
c'est un choix qui est fait est ce que
les professeurs aussi vont avoir droit
au vaccin en priorité qui sont eux face
à élèves et s'en remet à ce que toute la
journée
la question est aussi sur la table donc
c'est un choix politique de laisser les
écoles ouvertes même si on sait que
c'est des lieux de contamination qui
propulse ce variant angles est
extrêmement contaminant à l'échelle
nationale donc un choix comme un autre
qui nous emmène ce potentiellement vers
un confinement d'ici une quinzaine de
jours
et du côté des étudiants à partir du 25
janvier reprendront par demi groupes les
travaux dirigés pour les étudiants de
première année c'est une reprise là
aussi très progressive où on entend
parler ces derniers jours de d'une
situation parfois très difficilement
vécue par les étudiants qui se
retrouvent isolés les étudiants qui
vivent seuls certains qui paye un
logement pour faire leurs études loin de
leurs parents alors que les études se
font à distance
ceux qui ne peuvent pas avoir de petit
boulon qui sont obligés d'avoir recours
aux banques alimentaires qui sont dans
la précarité la plus totale a également
ceux qui tentent de se suicider ou qui
se suicident malheureusement qui sans
une détresse psychologique énorme ont
besoin de lien social
c'est un âge où on a besoin de se faire
des amis de vivre d'avoir cessé cette
chance de pouvoir échanger d'étudier et
là on a une mesure cosmétique pour dire
on a entendu votre détresse professeurs
et élèves et donc on va rouvrir les
premières années l'été dès le 25 janvier
donc d'ici une semaine pour voir un peu
ce que ça donne mais c'est anecdotique
c'est vraiment un cosmétique pour 10
rebonds ont fait un test et on va voir
mais on est loin d'une ouverture des
universités tel que demandé par tous en
disant on doit continuer de pouvoir
travailler parce que les jeunes sont les
moins touchées par ce virus parce que
ils ont besoin de ce monde social
aujourd'hui toute la politique sanitaire
vise à détruire le lien social sans pour
autant pouvait montrer des résultats sur
le plan sanitaire quant à la propagation
du virus
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et ça
montre que
les gouvernements et pas seulement le
gouvernement français là en l'occurrence
sont assez assez loin du compte quant à
la gestion efficace utile de cette crise
sanitaire
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse alexis
poulain